uh I'm 55 years old I grew up in South
Central
I come from a good family it's I got
four brothers one sister
at the age of 10 I was raped by two
older men
it was my friend's two brothers they you
know I went there to visit her
other two brothers I was there with my
friends and they tricked me into going
to watch a movie at the time they both
raped me one held me down the other one
did after one finished the other one
held me down
after that happens I went home
I didn't tell nobody
I didn't tell my mother what happened
at the age of 15 I lost the brother to a
drive-by shooting
at the age of 19.
I got pregnant
my son's father walked away I never seen
him again
by the time I was in labor at the
hospital
my sister called his father he came by
brought me a case of Pampers and a case
of milk and that's all he did for my son
I ended up raising my son
for the first five years by myself
I met this man
and he raised my son we ended up getting
married a year later after we met
he was a Muslim man I became a Muslim
woman
that marriage was okay until
six months into the marriage he under
marrying somebody else
um
at the age of 30 34
I was kind of hurt and disappointed
um
at that time when that happened to me
I started smoking crack cocaine
I was undercover closet smoker
I smoke crack I raised four kids in the
house which was my son my husband's two
grandsons his niece and my son
I would put them to bed
my husband went to work graveyard
when he left the house I'll go buy my
dope my crack
I was smoking the garage
I started little small portions at the
beginning
I'll go into the garage and get high by
five o'clock in the morning I was
through
six o'clock my husband got home 6 30 I
woke the kids up for school making
breakfast and I laid down to sleep
through the day with my husband because
I was getting high all night I did that
for like two years
one day my husband's brother told him
that I was a crackhead
my husband whipped his butt and beat him
down and knocked him out
at that time my husband found out I was
doing crack cocaine
he was not mad he was just disappointed
that I I didn't come to tell him what I
was doing
and when I finally told him what I was
doing I told him I was trying to mask
and medicate myself in the pain and hurt
that he put me through
after that he married somebody else
another woman
after that when he married another woman
the female said he married they wanted
they had money they had careers they had
property everything so they try to get
him to come to them
my husband Tom he was not leaving me
my husband was 25 years older than me
he did a documentary with hebo called
Bastards of the party
so if anybody would like to see it just
look it up on Google or HBO and you'll
see that it was bachelor's party
so a period of time my my mother-in-law
died she had property uh she left it to
me and my husband at the time
my husband have three older brothers
which they try to fight us and you take
the property so we ended up paying them
off
in 2002
I got tired of going through the pain
with my husband and I ended up
separating from my husband
the day I separated from him me and my
husband had an argument
he raised his hand at me and my son got
in between us
at that point in time my son said he
wanted to go live with his father
he called his father his father picked
him up and took him on and so I ended up
leaving my husband going around the
corner to her friends my addiction got
way way way too strong for me
so I was on the street you know I've
never one thing about me that my husband
told me don't ever lose your morals your
respect and integrity
I can say for myself as a crackhead as a
an addict
I've never traded drug I'm never traded
you know sex for drugs
I learned how to bite up and set up and
smoke at the same time to keep my
addiction going
I ended up in a program
when I went to the program I had a dream
that it was a woman living in my house
that I left with my husband
I left the program
and when I got to the house my dream was
true it was a woman living in my house
mind you I was separated already but at
that time I felt that he was still my
husband we was legally married so I told
a woman to leave my house
she didn't want to leave so I had to
drag her out the house
the same woman that I was living in my
house came back again
I went to visit my husband because he
was he had asthma and things like that
health issues so I went there to visit
my husband she was there
um
I went to the garage I got a gun I
kicked the door in and I pointed to her
and I told her I did not tell you not to
come back to my property that you would
not like the consequences
when I plant it again she took off
running
me and my husband struggle for the gun
it shot up in the air luckily there was
nobody living upstairs in the apartment
after that I left again
I didn't go back
my husband calls me and tells me he
wants to sell the property
he ends up selling the property and buys
a condominium in Inglewood California
he tells me to come on home you know I
will stop doing what I'm doing
so I had to think about it a week later
I told him okay I will come back the
first day I showed up at the house at
the condo first thing is the phone rings
it's a woman calling my husband
so I told him you lied to me I grabbed a
backpack and left everything behind and
I left
I never turned back
um
in 2010
actually 2000 and
seven I ended up in the Pueblo projects
in the neighborhood where I grew up at
my addiction got stronger
I started selling drugs
to keep up my addiction
I ended up renting a room in Huntington
Park fifteen hundred dollars a month
which I supplied my own drug habit it's
so drugs and paid my rent by myself
I was in the paper projects three years
doing me
in 2010
I get a call
that my son got killed in a dropper well
he got shot in drive by shooting
excuse me if I get sentimental because I
don't want to feel the pain
so I get the car
and his dad tells me that he got shot
I call my husband my husband shows up
picks me up
I tell his father that I'm on my way
by the time I got to the hospital in
Torrance UCLA
my husband had passed my son had passed
already
um
his father who raised him and his wife
took my legal rights
they signed the paperwork that they were
the parents legal parents so when I got
there I tried to get information they
wouldn't give me the information
they would not allow me to see my son uh
or if you eat anything
so I had an inverse breakdown
me and my husband left
um
so uh his biological father
was working with the street gangs an
advocate for the string games
he got the information that my son got
killed
he contacts me and finds me contacts me
and tells me
and I told him I already knew
he takes a insurance policy out of my
son
for twenty thousand dollars
and uh
kept the money which it kind of bother
me kept the money which I wasn't in for
the money it was my son
um
[Music]
I finally got the my rights back and I
picked up my son's body I had the Muslim
Community go and pick up my son's body
and uh a week later
I had the Muslim Community
uh to do the funeral
I was told to collect victims of crime
victims of crying gave me a check for
twelve thousand dollars
in my hand
I transferred the check over to the
Muslim Community which paid for all the
services and everything
the services cost me nine thousand
dollars so I donated the 3 000 to the
community to the Muslims
for their help for their assistance
um
after I buried my son I get a call from
his father
don't want to help me raise him and
tells me that where's my son's body and
I told him that I had already buried him
he was highly upset with me and he had a
closed casket I had a burial for my son
separate from what I had from my son
after that's a year and a half later
he passes away from colon cancer
um
when I went tried to retrieve my son's
belongings his graduation his diploma
and everything that my son had
they had got rid of everything which I
don't I didn't end up with nothing of my
son
all I had was memories of my son
um
I stayed clean
for 12 years
and then I relapsed again
um
I realized again
so in between that time from from
staying clean I I know a previous friend
of mine
we got together and uh
and uh getting me a place I wanted to
leave Los Angeles I ended up getting a
place in Palmdale
I left Los Angeles because I didn't want
the memories the the bad memories in
things like that from the gangs and
things like that
to remind me of my son's death
um
the detective that that took on the case
for my son gives me a call and tells me
that he's got some good news and some
bad news about the person that killed my
son
so he tells me and my husband come down
to the station we get down there
so as soon as we walk in he says Mrs
chillies
uh come on in you know have a seat I
said I don't want to sit down just tell
me what's going on he says what news do
you want the good or the bad I said tell
me the good news
and I'm thinking in my head that he's he
he's been arrested
that was not the case
he tells me that the boy that killed my
son was 19 years old he was a gang
member
and he's been killed in a drive-by
shooting
when he told me that news I had another
nervous breakdown and when I came to
I was sitting in a chair
uh when I came to I asked him what
happened he told me again and I said
Thank God Allahu Akbar alhamdulillah
I said that I didn't want to go through
the pain and everything all over again
the trial and everything going through
it if the boy was arrested
so that kind of gave me a relief
um
I was still clean mind you I was still
clean
um
like I said a minute ago I moved to
Palmdale okay what was the bad news
the bad news was that they could not
arrest him he was already dead
I ended up leaving La Los Angeles I went
to Palmdale got me a house and a friend
of mine was a truck driver for 25 years
I ended up learning how to drive trucks
I drive trucks across country which is
great I loved it paid vacation
um
that was that was great
so
um I ended up going to mental health
victims of crime pay for mental health I
went there for four years
I was diagnosed with post-traumatic
stress disorder bipolar depression
also neuropathy which is a diabetic
condition another condition
which I'm not a diabetic a specialist
cannot explain and tell me how I end up
with the condition
so I've been living with neuropathy
which is another condition where it
kills your nerves
and resulting neuropathy is in a
wheelchair
which I don't believe it because I have
faith in God which is a lie and I
believe in a lie
um
I had to stop driving trucks because it
took it all in my life from driving
trucks
I understood driving that I got into
In-Home Care Services which is a
provider for the State of California
I've been doing this for 16 years
and I believe my calling in in life is
to help people who can't help themselves
even though I'm you know disabled myself
but I I'm I believe in God and I believe
that he's given me the strength to keep
going
I thank God that I have not lost my mind
due to the trials and tribulations of
life
and losing my son that was my only child
I had he was 21 years old
um you're still using crack
presently uh when the covet this virus
covert hit
two years ago
the first year
I lost my husband to the covert
anyways
and when I lost my husband I lost
property I lost everything that I had
his daughter took a
power of attorney over him and took my
rights as his Legal Wife
she took everything which I could not go
see my husband because they would not
give me information as far as being his
Legal Wife
I relapsed and started smoking crack
again
at this present time I'm still smoking
crack
trying to mess the pain and hurt that I
have that I've been going through for
years
um
thank you trying to mess this pain and
hurt
um
when I get high I don't feel the pain I
don't feel the hurts I don't feel
nothing it medicates me
um
which y'all excuse me I'm doing it now
I have not hit I have not had one this
morning but I'm planning to go get me
one after I finish
um
so when my husband died
I ended up in a homeless program
which presently that's where I'm at now
I went through hopics a homeless program
I stayed there
um I ended up having a fight a physical
fight with my roommate she came in drunk
one day pushed me so I had to put my
hands on her I got put out she got moved
to another place
I ended up in another place another
house
do another a homeless program
I got put out there for a bottle of wine
that I got it was a gift for my birthday
so I got put out there
uh they wouldn't help me so I ended up
in a motel hotel room for six to six
months paying out of my own pocket
mind you I still work I have a job you
know I'm still doing in-home care
um
I ended up meeting this guy
hmm
the last past 10 months and meeting this
guy he has a Section 8 voucher I moved
in with him
in order to stop paying 120 a night out
of my pocket
everything was good at the beginning
but then again
he turned it into Dr Jekyll and Mr Hyde
this person tried to kill me with a
metal pipe
this happened
in February at the end of February
he beat me to where he cracked my head
open
he fractured my left my left hand my my
wrist my and my hand
um
when he turned around
I escaped the room
and I ran down the hallway and I called
her for help
this one girl came out of her room and
helped me
oh my God what happened and I told her
what happened
also Delirious I don't know if I was
going to Common but I thank God that I
didn't get knocked out or I thank God
that he didn't paralyzed me from my neck
down because I believe he tried to
paralyze Mary to kill me
she took me downstairs caught up hair
medicine and the police
paramedics couldn't come to the building
where I was at because it was a domestic
I ended up going across they ended up
going to General Hospital UC Medical
Center I got there and LAPD showed up
they took my statement they took
pictures and everything
they turned it in and
um
I pressed charges
well the cool thing about it that
frustrates me now is that
they turned in the case to the DA's
office
I get away from the detectives telling
me that the da is not picking another
case
it was supposed to have been an average
aggravated assault with bodily injury
which I was really [__] up bad
now they tell me that the da is not
picking up the case
I'm trying to figure out why they won't
tell me why
now like I told the detective what he
was supposed to say I killed me before
y'all pick up the case and arrest this
person
I heard nothing yet
so that's that's another you know issue
that I have that I can't understand
why this person is still out in the
streets
women Ladies If you ever get into a
relationship that's abusive
physical
please leave the person don't stay
around
because once he hits you he will do it
again
this was the first time he put his hands
on me but he tried he hurt me really bad
you know so please if you ever meet
somebody it don't matter if you love him
or not get away from the person
please get away from him take it from my
experiences
I thank God that I'm still here and I'm
breathing
I'm okay but
I don't understand why the city of Los
Angeles will not pick up this guy and
put him in jail
um I don't want him to do this thing
what he did to me to somebody else
because I know he will
I know he will
Dr Jekyll and Mr Hyde
um
so now
I'm in a shelter like I said I got
approved from my section 8 voucher
I'm just waiting for them to give me my
voucher in my hand
once I get my voucher in my hand I'm
moving back to Palmdale
I got plans and goals my backbone has
gone my husband which was my backbone
not have to sell Visa support and
self-sufficient for myself
I plan on starting a business for
disabled people disabled women
which is I believe it's my calling since
I'm a provider
and that's what I'm gonna do in order to
help people that can help themselves
like I said I thank God I'm still here
and I'm breathing I'm still saying mine
I lost my mind after everything that
I've been through
I thank him holy heart
you know he's great
so once I get my voucher in my hand I
will leave Los Angeles and leave my
addiction and people places and things
behind and start a new life
that's my plan that's my goal and I
believe that's what God has plans for me
to do
so
thank you for listening to me and I
appreciate
and please women ladies please please I
beg you please get out of a realistic
relationship before he ends up killing
you please take my advice
and y'all have a blessed day thank you
very much
thank you Mary you're welcome